The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK,
so let's get started.
I'm just trying
to wire myself up.
OK.
So before we get into
the PowerPoint here.
So basically, what I'm doing is
I'm picking up from the point
where we left last time,
where we're discussing waves.
And what I would like to do
now is derive a wave equation
basically, for a
mathematical form
that should allow us to predict
different kinds of waves.
Of waves, not the waves.
All right, so what
I start with here.
I start with a general function,
psi, of an argument, eta.
So for those of you who are not
fluent in Greek, this is psi,
and this is eta.
OK.
At the moment, these
don't necessarily
have a physical meaning.
But in order to
produce a wave out
of this function,
what I can do is
I can write it as psi,
or f of z comma t,
equals psi of z minus ct.
OK, now why is that a wave?
First of all, z now has
become a spacial coordinate.
t, as usual, is time.
So if you actually hide time.
So now time is zero.
Time is a constant or
something like that.
Then you actually have
basically the same argument.
But if you allow
time to increase,
then you can see that
the time increase will
have the effect of
sliding the same shape
along the spatial axis.
So for example, let's take this
as our reference point here.
The first peak after
you advance time
a little further than
this point has moved fast,
has moved to the right.
And how much is this distance?
Well, anybody?
This is easy.
I'm just trying to see if the
people in Boston have woken up.
Yes?
Nobody's awake in Boston.
So this distance equals ct.
Because if I set the
argument of this function
to zero, then basically I
recover my original function.
So basically as I
advance time, the fact
is that this waveform
moves to the right.
And at the moment, there's
no obvious motivation
for why I'm going to do
what I'm about to do.
But please take my word
for it for a while.
I'm going to take two
partial derivatives.
I'm going to take
df dz, and df dt.
OK, df dz equals basically
c prime, where c prime--
I use c prime simply to
denote the derivative of c
with respect to its
mysterious argument.
So that's very easy.
What about the affinity?
That's right.
I have to apply the
chain rule, because there
is a multiplicative
argument inside.
So this is going to be
minus c times c prime.
So because c prime appears
in both places over here,
I can combine these
equations and say, df over dz
equals minus 1 over c, df dt.
So that is a partial
differential equation.
And you might say, well, what
I did is a bit stupid, right?
Because I had a relatively
simple explanation
for the wave.
I actually had the wave
just in front of me.
And what I did is I wrote a
partial differential equation
which is not very intuitive.
But the benefit of doing
that is, of course,
that the wave that I wrote here
is a very special, very limited
kind of wave that propagates
without changing shape,
without anything
fancy happening.
We know from experience,
for example, in real life,
if you have ever
seen water waves.
Water waves, they
don't quite propagate.
They change shape in all
kinds of complicated ways.
So even though I
derive this equation
from that simple shape.
What we'll see a
little bit later
that this equation
actually can describe
much more general waves.
We're not quite done
yet, because the question
that I derived here applies
for a wave moving to the right.
I can equally well
contribute a wave
that is moving to the left.
And in this case, what
I would have to do
is I would have to write
f of z comma t equals psi
or z plus ct.
A little bit of thought
will convince you now
that if you advance
time, then the wave
will have actually to move to
the left, towards negative z
in order to maintain
its argument.
And if I do the same game now.
Again, I can write
df dz equals c prime.
That did not change.
This time, df dt
equals plus c prime.
Now, I have another partial
differential equation,
df dz equals 1 over c, df dt.
OK, let me put
back the equation.
So this is a wave going
to the left, backwards.
And I had another equation,
df dz equals minus 1
over c, df dt.
And that is a way of
going to the right.
OK.
You can see very easily that
if you take a second derivative
of these equations.
Let's go back to the first one.
If you do the second derivative,
d squared f dz square.
You will pick up an extra minus
sign from the same equation.
And you will find that it is
1 over c square, d square f,
dt square.
You can do the same
in this equation.
There's no sign
here to begin with.
But there is one
over here, c square,
d squared f, dt squared.
So basically, this
single equation.
This single equation can
describe both forward
and backward propagating waves.
And this equation.
Actually, it's a three
dimensional version.
Not this one, but it's
three dimensional version.
It has the name
Helmholtz wave equation.
And because of Helmholtz,
it's a little bit difficult
to pronounce.
Actually, that's
not the real one.
Anyway, it's a very commonly
encountered wave equation.
So typically we
simply omit Helmholtz,
and we say wave equation.
Now, why you might want to
distinguish this as opposed to
are there other wave equations?
Yes, there is the
Schrodinger equation.
There is the
Klein-Gordon equation.
For those of you who
do fluid mechanics,
there is a Korteweg-de Vries
equation, also known as KDV.
There's a bunch of
different wave equations.
So we need some way
to discriminate.
Nevertheless, the
other wave equations,
they are referred
with their name.
So when you want to refer
to Schrodinger's equation,
you say Schrodinger's equation.
By convention, when
you say wave equation,
you mean this one,
so the Helmholtz.
OK.
So this is all very
nice, but it's actually
down on your slide.
So there's no reason to agonize
over what I did over here.
What I would like to
remind you before I
move on is for the
simple case of a--
first of all, you
can imagine that this
is a very general
kind of solution.
Because what is c?
After all, I put up this
strange shape over here.
I didn't say where it came from.
So for that matter, if someone
gives you the wave question,
how can you go
ahead and solve it?
Well, we're not going to do
this in great detail here.
This is a little bit beside
the scope of the class.
But generally, if you need to
solve a partial differential
like this one, you need
additional information.
You need the initial conditions.
How did the wave start
at that time equals zero?
And you also need the
boundary conditions.
So what happens to the
wave as it expands?
Sometimes, the boundary
condition is at infinity.
Maybe the wave is not bounded.
It can propagate
outwards all the way.
And that's a good
example of what
happens if you are flying with a
helicopter on top of the ocean.
And you drop a--
I don't know.
You drop a stone into
the surface of the ocean.
Then the wave that you generate,
the wave that you generate.
To a good approximation, you
can use infinite boundary
conditions.
Because the ocean is not quite
infinite, but very large.
If you generate in a
wave in a small channel,
then you might have to
include boundary conditions.
Because the wave
will be confined
by the walls of the channel.
And we will see later
that this is actually
quite commonly the case.
In optics, we don't
call them channels.
We'll call them wave guides.
But the boundary conditions can
actually significantly alter
the shape of the wave.
So what I did here is
just to give you an idea,
I quote unquote, "solved."
Nothing interesting
happens here,
but this is actually
solution of the wave
equation with a particular
initial condition, where
time equals zero.
The wave is a sinusoid.
I said that this is my equation.
And I say that f
of z at t equals 0,
equals some sinusoid amplitude
a, and wave number k.
If that is the case,
then by inspection.
I don't have to do anything.
All very important.
And what I did not write
down, but it is implied,
is that the boundary
conditions are free.
So this wave is
free to go as far
as it pleases without
any special constraints.
So if that is the case, then you
can write the solution almost
by inspection.
Half of z comma t equals
a cosine kz minus ct.
And you can see by inspection
here that because of the way
I wrote it, this
actually satisfies
both the partial differential
equation, the wave equation,
and the boundary condition.
So therefore, this is a proper
solution of the wave equation.
In fact, I only
wrote half of it.
The wave, remember, it can go
forwards, and can go backwards.
To cover both cases, I actually
write the solution this way.
With the data that I
have here, actually, I
don't have enough to specify.
Or actually, in principle,
the wave can go both ways.
I would have to apply to give
you additional information
to know which actually happened.
The other thing that
I wanted to point out,
which is not really difficult,
but it takes some getting used
to, is the various
terms that appear
inside this equation over here.
So the term that we have
been very familiar with
is the wavelength.
There's another of those
crazy Greek symbols.
It's called lambda.
And the wavelength is
related to the quantity
that we have over here, as
2 pi over lambda equals k.
So lambda is the
wavelength, as I said.
K is known as the wave number.
So the relationship
that they have
is if you think of the
wavelength as a period--
which it is, the period of
the wave in the space domain--
then k would actually be
the angular frequency.
But we'll call it wave number
to keep them separated.
OK.
Equivalently, you can define
the actual angular frequency
of the wave.
Usually this goes
by the symbol omega.
And from this
equation over here,
very simply you can see that
if you wanted to write it
in the form a cosine kz
minus omega t, then clearly,
omega is the angular frequency.
And when comparing
the two equations,
you can see that
omega equals kc.
So the angular
frequency, then, is
related to the spatial
frequency, the wave number,
and the speed of the wave.
And of course, this
is nothing new.
We've seen this equation before,
but we saw it in disguise.
And that's why I'm
going through this.
Because all the symbols,
they can be played around
with quite a bit.
So this equation, I can rewrite.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
is like this.
So omega is the
angular frequency.
I also have the
plane, so to speak.
Frequency nu, which is
related as omega over 2 pi.
One of them goes
[INAUDIBLE] radians.
I'm sorry, it's measured
in full radians per second.
This is omega.
Nu is measured in hertz,
simply inverse seconds.
Bless you.
So I can substitute
in this equation.
Omega is 2 pi times nu.
k, according to my equation
over here, is 2 pi up on lambda.
And c is c.
So the two pis cancel here.
The two pis cancel here,
and I end up with equation c
equals lambda nu, which
I think we've already
seen a couple of times before.
Who call it the dispersion
relation of the wave.
So this is how all
this came about.
I haven't said anything
new about this.
I'm just trying to point
out the different ways
that this equation
can manifest itself.
And the other two terms that
we encountered last time,
and I wanted to remind you.
One is the amplitude
of the wave.
This is this
constant a over here.
For some reason, in the slide,
they decided to call it a0.
Anyway, it is the same thing.
And also, so we said last
time that in general, the wave
can also have a phase delay.
So in here, I can not
cite the constant plus
fee, which does not really
do anything by itself.
All it does if you
wish equivalently,
it shifts the time origin.
So that's a relatively
trivial thing
because after all, I am free to
start my clock whenever I want.
If I have a wave
that never changes,
I can start my clock
whenever I want.
So it doesn't really
make a big difference.
But we saw last time that if
you have two waves that are,
as we said, interference--
or they're simultaneously
happening, so to speak--
then the relative phase
delay between the two
can actually be
quite significant.
And I will play
this movie again.
In this case, the two
waves are actually--
they have the same
phase between them.
In other words, if you
look at the center,
they're both simultaneously
bright or simultaneously dark.
Whereas in the other case,
it's the other way around.
They're off by pi.
So when one is maximum,
the other is minimum.
I think it is worth
playing this one.
This also has the
interesting effect
that this can hypnotize you.
So for those of you who are in
Boston and not fully awake yet.
Yes.
Oh, so when you ask a question,
you need to push the button.
AUDIENCE: So for
them for now are
two waves travel in
the opposite direction.
They have same amplitude, about
perfect cancel each other.
So in this case, where
does the energy go?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: They don't
quite cancel each other, right?
So as we will see I will
actually do this in a second.
It's called a standing wave.
So you will see that
they don't quite cancel.
They just produce a, well,
what is called a standing wave.
So I will get to your question.
I think it's actually
coming up next.
Yeah, so give me a second and
I will get to your question.
So that is a standing wave.
So like your colleague
asked over here.
Suppose that you have a
superposition of two waves.
Now, both are solutions
to the wave equation.
Now, by truce.
I don't want to
do the proof here.
It takes three lines.
But by its looks, this is a
linear differential equation.
So basically, it means that
if you know one solution,
you know another solution.
And then you add
these two solutions
after multiplying by
arbitrary constants.
The result from the
addition is still
a solution to this equation.
A very fundamental property that
we use again and again later
in the class.
So that said, suppose
that I pick two solutions
that I already saw.
One of them is a forward
propagating wave,
the other is a backward
propagating wave.
So here they are.
The one with the minus
is propagating forward.
The one with the plus
is propagating backward.
So your colleague
here asked, what will
happen if I superimpose them?
So one of them is
going to the right.
One is to the left.
Are they going to cancel?
What are they going to do?
OK, so this is a computational.
So perhaps you
should not trust it.
After all, what is this?
But anyway, this is
what I got in Matlab
when I simulated this.
OK, let me play this again.
So this is the result
of the two waves.
OK.
I pushed the button.
I did not play the movie again.
I revealed the derivation,
but that's quite all right.
Actually, I meant to do
this on the free hand here.
OK, never mind.
Ignore what you
see on the slide,
and just watch the whiteboard.
I guess I can call it
whiteboard, can't I?
I mean, it is a whiteboard.
OK, so here are the two waves.
So I actually omitted.
I should have said that not only
are they counterpropagating,
but also, I pick them
both to be harmonic waves.
So that we can do
the math easily.
OK, so let's add this out.
So we picked the
identical amplitude.
So one of them will be
written as-- did I use a,
or was it-- a, yeah, OK.
OK, now, for generality.
I don't really have to,
but for generality, I also
added the phase, a phase
delay field to the first wave.
So this one is forward.
And then I have the
other one, which
looks very similar, except
for this devious minus
sign that goes backward.
OK.
And the superposition
principle says
that I can simply
add the two waves,
and the summation is still a
solution to the wave equation,
therefore, still a valid wave.
OK, so what is the result?
So now, I don't know how to
tell you to remember this.
Most people look it up
in books of trigonometry.
I have a second mnemonic for
it, but I will not tell you.
So there's a mnemonic
that says if you have
the sum of two cosines equals--
now, this is a
mathematical property,
so there's no intuition
to be derived here.
This is just obtained by
trigonometric manipulation.
Equals twice cosine, a plus
b over 2, cosine a minus b
over 2.
So I never remember this one.
I will tell you
actually my mnemonic.
It's nothing strange.
All I remember is that if you
have cosine of two things,
it equals--
let me write it cleanly
on a clean piece of paper.
So cosine of two things.
It has a minus sign here.
And sine of two things.
OK, this, you have memorized.
And you can see very
easily that from these two,
you can obtain the
equation we said before.
Because, for example, you can
write cosine alpha plus beta,
plus minus beta equals cosine
alpha cosine beta minus
plus sine alpha sine beta.
OK, so if you add
the term with a plus,
and the term with a minus.
The sine terms evaporate, and
you end up with the identity
that they had before.
So this is my mnemonic
for remembering this one.
We will not have to do this
too often because last time,
if you remember, we
introduced phasors.
We introduced a complex
notation for waves,
so we don't have to deal with
this trigonometry very often.
In this case,
there's no way out.
Well, actually,
there's a way out,
but it is simpler
to do it this way.
So now, I have
basically a equals kz
minus omega t plus phi.
b equals plus omega t plus phi.
So if you apply my
formula here, you
will find that the
wave actually--
OK, the amplitude is the same.
I pick up a factor of two.
So it is two.
And then I have the
cosine of the sum.
So if I sum the two, the
time term will disappear.
So we'll have cosine.
Well, you get twice of it,
but there's a factor of two
here, so they cancel.
It'll be cosine kz plus phi.
And if I subtract the
two, then naturally,
the spatial terms and
the phase will disappear.
And I will get the
cosine omega t.
OK, now do I believe Matlab?
I think I should believe
Matlab, because let's see
what Matlab saw.
Here, time is frozen.
So you'll see
basically the same term
where this has been replaced by
constant, because I froze time.
So in there, this looks like a
sinusoid of the same frequency
as we had before.
And actually, of course, you
have no way of knowing that.
But the waves that I
entered had an amplitude
that was half of this.
So basically, the
factor of two was also
reproduced by my simulation.
OK, and if I play
the movie again,
it is basically like
unfreezing time.
OK, so here, I
have unfrozen time.
And you see that I get
a sinusoidal variation
in the time domain.
So therefore, that's my
term cosine omega t here.
So basically, the Matlab
simulation is correct.
So we're very happy.
OK.
So now, let me come
to your question.
What happens to the
wave when it vanishes?
First of all, it
doesn't really vanish.
I don't know how to go back.
So it does look
like at some point
the wave vanishes,
and then it reappears.
OK, it is a little bit
annoying that it vanishes.
But in electromagnetic
waves, and usually
in other kinds of
waves, we don't worry
about instantaneous energy.
We worry about the
average energy.
So what you can see here is that
the average energy is actually
conserved.
Because as the wave oscillates
from a maximum to a minimum,
it's average energy
remains the same.
Now, you might ask, well,
what happens in between?
I mean, what happens when
this wave has gone to zero?
Again, I will [INAUDIBLE]
kinds of electromagnetic waves.
What you have done here
is you have basically
launched two waves that are
moving in opposite directions.
So who is providing the energy?
Well, if you are providing
the energy on one end,
and someone else is providing
the energy on the other end.
What happens when
the two waves cancel
is that the energy
is actually stored
in another place, which does
not show up in this equation.
That's one way to
think about it.
So if you remember
when I saw-- actually,
you don't remember,
because you were not
in the class one week ago.
But I showed an example of a
simple harmonic oscillator.
So simple harmonic oscillator
goes from zero velocity
maximum potential energy to the
edge, where the velocity now
is--
I'm sorry, to the rest position,
where the velocity's maximum
and the potential
energy has become zero
at the rest position.
So it's the same kind of thing.
The kinetic energy disappears.
Well, what happens to it?
It has become potential.
So it is very similar to this.
The energy has become
potential energy,
and you don't see it here.
AUDIENCE: OK, maybe a
follow up on the question.
So now, let's
assume the two wave
are traveling along
the same direction,
and they are out of phase by pi.
In this case, they'd be a
perfect cancelling each other.
So where does the energy go?
Just for your information,
the previous answer, again.
Such thing will not
happen in the first place,
but just not comfortable
with this answer.
So I would like to
know your comments.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
[INAUDIBLE] the wave
start at the pi phase shift.
It's equivalent to not having
launched any wave at all.
Whoever launched the
two waves basically
canceled his own action.
So if you think about it
physically, what happened?
First of all, have the two
waves been launched at infinity,
or at the finite time?
AUDIENCE: So for the [INAUDIBLE]
have, and as that equal zero.
And this wave traveling
to the positive direction
and continuously.
Now, I'm not sure another wave
added them [INAUDIBLE] that
equals minus 10.
But this show is that
we've only lasted
for three period for the input.
So as we are traveling
into a positive direction,
it is going to cancel three
periods out the previous wave,
right?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Now you're
making it a little bit more
complicated.
Because what happens to
the edges of the wave?
Are you multiplying
by a boxcar function?
What happens later?
You're not given
enough information
to answer the question.
Because then we had three
periods cancel, but then
what happens later?
Did you just stop the wave?
AUDIENCE: I'm still
not so sure, yeah.
That's why I check.
Yeah, thanks.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: The
question's a bit ill defined,
I guess.
So I can not answer it.
But I can tell you this.
Suppose that I launch a
wave at some time, and then
a certain time later,
I launch the same wave
with biphasic trait.
So there's no doubt that
the two waves at this point
will cancel.
So what happened to the energy?
Well, it is equivalent to
thinking that I did not really
launch a second wave
with a pi phase shift.
But I actually
turned off the swings
that was producing my first
wave in the first place.
There might be a tangent
or something like that,
but in fact, I've just
canceled the wave.
So simply stop the
flow of energy.
Everybody happy
with this answer,
or should we discuss this?
And I think to realize that
actually this is interesting,
that we brought up energy.
In the standing wave, the energy
is actually not going anywhere.
Well, that's one way
to think about it.
It's not going anywhere.
Or you can think
about it in the way
that the energy is
going back and forth.
I did not realize, actually.
I did not the phasors
last time, did I?
Did I?
I guess I didn't.
So I guess I pulled a fast one.
A few minutes ago, I was
talking about the difficulty
of trigonometry.
And I said that's why I
introduced phasors last time.
I was mistaken.
I had not introduced
any phasors last time.
I'm introducing phasors now.
And the reason, of course,
that we're introducing phasors
is because we don't
want to have to remember
complicated identities
like this one.
By the way, another
point that I would
like to bring up before
I move on to phasors
is that the wave
that I'm showing here
is actually very different
than the traveling wave that
led us to the wave equation.
You'll agree with that.
That looks very
different, both in the way
it behaves with time
and space, and the way
it looks like an equation.
Yet, it still originated
from the same wave equation.
So this is actually the power of
partial differential equations
and superposition.
That I took two solutions
with my partial differential
equation that were not
particularly interesting,
I superimposed them, and
then all of a sudden,
I created another
solution, which
is still a very valid wave,
but we have totally different.
It is a stationary wave.
It has this oscillation,
and so on and so forth.
So that is why we bother to
write this partial differential
equation, because it
allows us to generate
a much richer set
of waves that are,
of course, very
important in practice.
Standing waves
happen all the time.
OK, so now, let's go to phasors.
OK, so just like before,
I wrote two waves
that were propagating
in opposite directions.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to write two waves that are
phase shifted by pi over two.
So one of them is cosine
kz minus omega t plus phi.
And the other is
phase shifted by pi
over 2, which means instead
of a cosine, it is a sine.
OK, both are valid solutions
to the wave equation
with different
initial conditions,
but that doesn't bother us.
They're still valid solutions.
Therefore, their superposition
is also a solution.
And I said before that when
you do a linear superposition,
you can also multiply the
waves by arbitrary constants.
I said this a little
bit fast, but I hope
that remember that I said it.
In fact, in this class, we
have evidence of what I said
and what I did not say.
Then go back to the video and
see if I said it, and I did.
So I will pick a very
particular constant,
which may sound like a crazy
choice, but I will pick it.
And that is the imaginary
constant, i, also known
as one of the two
square root of minus 1.
OK, what is this now?
So the first confession
that I will make
is that it is not
physical anymore.
There's no such thing
as a complex wave.
The waves that we see
around us are real.
They can be measured
by instruments,
such as oscilloscope, scanners,
I don't know what else.
They're real.
As far as I know, nobody has
ever measured anything complex.
However, what I'm doing here
is mathematically correct,
even if it has no
physical meaning.
And as it turns out, it
provides a huge mathematical
convenience.
So I'm justified in doing it
as long as I remember what
is the physics that is behind.
And the physics
that is behind it
is that every time I
see a wave like this,
I have to remember that
the physical quantity is
the real part.
So the physical wave--
the one that I can
actually measure, observe,
generate with natural means--
is the real part.
The imaginary part is
something that I added
for mathematical convenience.
And it isn't reality because
I forget whose formula.
It is called the De Moivre.
Anyway, one of those.
D-E?
Moivre, yeah.
AUDIENCE: De Moivre.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
De Moivre, yeah.
OK, I got it right.
So De Moivre, then, if
I remember correctly,
that's how you spell it.
De Moivre says that this thing
here is a complex exponential.
So that's very nice
because for example,
if you have to multiply two
cosines, it's a big pain.
You have to remember the trig
to multiply two exponential.
It is trivial.
You just add their phases,
I mean, their exponents.
So a lot of inconveniences
to be to be expected.
So this representation, it
comes with different names,
which are sometimes
used confusingly
in an interchangeable way.
So some people call
this a phasor notation.
I prefer to call this the
complex representation
of the wave.
It becomes a phasor
when we drop--
I'm going to do
something nasty here.
OK, remember that I can
write this as a project.
So I can write this as e to the
ikz, e to the minus i omega t,
e to the i phi.
OK.
If you recall during the
beginnings of the class,
we saw that the wavelength
in the middle changes.
But there is a property of
the wave that does not change.
And that property,
if you recall,
is the temporal
frequency, omega, or nu,
which are related by two pi.
That is true in linear media.
Of course, there is
a class of optics
called non-linear, where
actually, the frequency can
change.
It can double, or it can
half, or [INAUDIBLE] of things
can happen to it.
But in this class, we don't deal
with these complicated things.
We just deal with linear optics.
So in linear optics,
the temporal frequency
of the light, no matter
what happens to the light.
If it goes through
glass and reflects,
and all kinds of things.
The temporal frequency
remains the same.
So when we deal with optical
waves of a single frequency--
that is the quality's fixed
and the medium is linear--
then this term is
actually superfluous.
We don't have to remind
ourselves that the light goes
like e to the minus omega t.
It does, but we don't
have to write it.
Because if we keep writing
it, it clutters our equations.
So we simply drop it.
We drop it.
Very important to remember.
We are allowed to
drop it if we know
that we have a single color in
our system, a single frequency.
If there is multiple
frequencies,
we can not do that anymore.
Because then these frequencies
have to adapt in a certain way,
and you have to keep track
of their additive phases.
So we can only drop
this term if we--
two conditions.
If we know that we
have a linear medium,
and a single frequency light
propagating in that medium.
So in my terminology, at
least, after we drop this term,
then it becomes a phasor.
So what is left?
e to the ikz plus 5.
That, I call a phasor.
And you notice
what happened there
is I only left the spatial
dependency of the wave
plus the phase delay.
The temporal variation is--
it's hidden.
It is not gone.
It is just hidden.
OK, now let's see
this in action.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to rederive the standing
wave, but using the phasor.
So you can see how nice
and simple it comes out,
and we don't have
to agonize over it.
But before I do it, I actually
have to solve a little problem.
And the problem is that I
did this very nice derivation
for the phasor of the
forward propagating wave.
What about the phasor for the
backward propagating wave?
The backward propagating wave
will be something of this sort.
So this will always
forward, right?
Let me write the backward.
I think I have enough
space here, so I can do it.
OK, so the backward
would be something
of the sort of the form
of cosine, az plus omega t
plus phi.
And it is very inconvenient.
Because the way I
got the phasor is
I got rid of a term of the
forward to the minus omega t.
If I add the
imaginary part here,
I don't have a term e to the
minus omega t, so I'm stuck.
But I can do some
mathematical trickery.
Now, this is pure
trickery, but it works.
The trick, it is the following.
We know that the cosine
is an even function.
So this is actually identical.
I can replace it,
in other words,
with the cosine of
the negative element.
No harm done.
It is still a backward
propagating wave.
Nothing has changed.
It is the same equation.
Now, according to my good
principle here, I add.
That is not the same as before.
Because the sign
is an odd function.
But this is a
non-physical term, anyway.
I just put it there for
mathematical convenience,
so I don't particularly care.
I'm very happy,
because the real part
is the same as I started with.
What the imaginary part does--
as long as it's
mathematically convenient,
I couldn't care less.
OK, so that gives me the
license to write this.
Now, this, of course,
equals e to the minus
ikz minus omega t minus phi.
Now very happy, because
I did get a term e
to the minus i omega t in the
phase of this exponential.
And therefore, I can drop
it to produce my phasor.
So the last one, then,
is that the phasor
for the backward wave is e
to the minus ikz minus i phi.
In other words, if I give you
a forward propagating wave,
and you compute its phasor.
And then I asked you, well, what
is the phasor for the backward
propagating wave?
Well, all you do is you flip
the sign and the exponent.
Whoa.
Where did this come from?
I think this is an old paper
from some previous lecture.
But anyway, ignore this.
I have to remember to ask
for a new paper next time.
OK, so what I will do now.
Let me reproduce
the standing wave.
So the standing wave is
using the phasors now.
It's e to the ikz plus phi.
That is the forward wave, plus
e to the minus ikz minus i phi.
That is the backward wave.
Can I deal with that?
Well, yes, actually.
Because, again, De Moivre
says that if you add
two exponential of this form--
notice they have the same
phase within a minus sign--
I will simply get two
i's cosine az plus phi.
So I've got my thing here.
Not quite, though,
because the standing wave.
It had the cosine omega t term.
What happened to
the cosine omega t?
Oh, come on.
OK.
What happened to
the cosine omega t?
Well, remember, we neglected
an e to the minus omega t.
We didn't really neglect it.
We hit it, because we
didn't want to carry it
when we write the equation.
First of all, if I don't care
about the temporal variation,
I don't really have
to do anything.
I'm done.
But if I want to put a
temporal variation back in,
what I have to do is I have
to put back what I took
when it did not belong to me.
And what did not belong to me is
this e to the minus i omega t.
OK, I put it back.
Now, that is still
not a physical wave
because it is complex.
How can I find the
actual, physical wave?
Well, I have to
take its real part.
And the real part is easy here,
because the only complex thing
is this exponential.
So if I take the real part
of this, of all of this now.
It would simply be 2 cosine
kz plus phi cosine omega t.
And I'm done.
I've actually produced
my standing wave.
Any questions?
We're almost done here.
So I have about three minutes.
So I think I'll use them
to finish up this lecture,
so we can move on to
bigger and better things.
The question that I wrote before
is the one dimensional wave
equation.
Because the waves
that I've written.
They can only go down
one spatial axis, z.
The more generalized,
of course, situation
is three dimensional waves.
And what you see here
is the generalized three
dimensional wave equation,
which, of course,
I will not derive.
But it can be pretty
easily derived
using the same arguments
that we did before,
except you have to generalize
in the third dimension.
And this produces
things that we've
seen before in
geometrical optics,
for example, the plain wave.
Except now, you see
the wave description,
it is you have alternating
positive and negative--
how do you call those--
peaks and troughs,
which are propagating
along an arbitrary angle.
Now, they can go in
any angle in 3D space.
So you just see a
cross-section here.
Or you can have a spherical
wave, which we saw it before.
It starts at a given point,
and then radiates outwards.
So that's a spherical wave.
Well, we're not
quite finished, yet.
But I think we're
almost out of time.
So I think I'll stop
here, and we can still
continue next time.
Are there any questions?
There's no homework
due on Wednesday,
so what I would like
to-- you have a question?
Yeah, there's a question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: How is
the wave equation
intuitively different from
simple harmonic oscillator?
The variation in space depends
on the relation in time.
So that's coupling?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah, the
mathematical answer, of course,
is very easy.
They're simply
harmonic oscillators
in an ordinary
differential equation.
This is a partial
But let me think how to
formulate a physical answer.
OK, so the physical answer is
that the harmonic oscillator
is a singly particle
whose position you
track as a function of time.
A wave is a distributed
physical system.
So you can think of a wave--
in this case, for example.
You can interpret
the physical meaning
of these black and white stripes
as particles which are moving.
For example, the particle
that is on the white stripe
is moving up.
The particle in the black
stripe is moving down.
If I play the wave
again, what you
will see that the particles
are kind of executing
a coordinated motion.
Because you have particles that
were down, then they go up,
and then they go down again.
But they go out in
a coordinated motion
throughout the entire plane.
How do they know?
Well, there is a physical
system associated with this.
For example, this could be a
membrane with the sound wave
propagating on it.
And now the reason that
particles are connected,
that they execute a
coordinated motion
is because of the
interatomic forces
between the membrane particles.
If it is an
electromagnetic wave,
then it is a field
that is distributed.
And, of course, it
knows to be connected
because of Maxim's equations.
There's things like charge
conservation and so on that
force it to act this way.
So a wave is actually
a distributed system,
where the physics force
an extended systems--
particles, or fields, or
whatever the case may be--
to execute a coordinated motion.
That's the difference between
that simple harmonic oscillator
where you just
have one particle.
Now, you can go from
one to the other.
Imagine you take a single
harmonic oscillator.
That's a good one.
So let me draw it here.
Wow, we're actually going
backwards now in the knowledge
that they used in the past.
So you take a simple
harmonic oscillator.
Here it is, a pendulum.
This is a simple
harmonic oscillator.
Then you couple it with
a separate pendulum.
And how do you couple--
they're not coupled
at the moment,
but you can couple
them, for example,
by connecting the
spring in between.
But that's not quite a wave.
But you can see now that
because I coupled them,
if I kick one of
these, it will also
cause the other one to move,
so they become coordinated.
Well, now, let me generalize.
Imagine that I have a bunch
of harmonic oscillators.
And, in fact, I can make them
infinite, and I couple them.
Now, in fact, the system will
become wave like, in the sense
that if you kick it at one end.
Let's say not at infinity.
Let's say it starts
actually here,
and then it goes to infinity.
So if you kick it at one
end, then the disturbance
will actually propagate
very similar to a wave.
It's a discrete wave,
but it's still a wave.
So you can go from one to
the other by introducing kind
of a coordination mechanism.
So it is the coupling here
that does the coordination.
Any other questions?
We can stay here, actually.
Nobody claims the classrooms
either here or there.
So if you have more
questions, I'll
be happy to stay
and answer them.
But about the
phasors, is it clear?
When I was your age,
when I was a student,
I was also very
upset by phasors.
Because they look very much
like mathematical trickery.
I mean, I'm trying to find my--
I guess that's one benefit
of this over the whiteboard,
that I have a history
of what I did.
But yeah.
But the phasors,
they look very much
like mathematical trickery.
I mean, this looks like
someone pulled it out of a hat.
But the only reason to
justify it in your mind
is that it provides huge
mathematical convenience.
Now, this looks like
a trivial thing.
I mean, the derivation
of the standing wave
was maybe four lines with
trigonometry, two lines
with the complex exponential.
So OK, why mess with
complex numbers?
Well, try superposition.
If you have several
waves superimposed,
or if you have an
integral, a continuum
of superimposed waves,
which we will see very soon.
Like Fourier
transforms and so on.
Fourier transforms are extremely
inconvenient if you write them
as cosine transforms.
Big mess.
If you write them as
complex exponentials,
it's actually very
simple to do the math.
It is a very, very time
saving tool, basically.
Strangely enough, it
leads to some insights
that real numbers
do not give you.
So that's an
additional convenience.
We will appreciate that later.
For now, it is simply the
mathematical convenience
that drives this
mathematical wizardry.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You're saying [INAUDIBLE]
angular frequency
and the temporal frequency are
different, or it's the same?
Because you initially defined
omega as angular frequency.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I
confuse those myself, usually,
the terms.
Usually nu.
Usually nu is called
the frequency.
And it is measured in hertz.
2 pi nu is measured
in radians per second.
Angular frequency, isn't it?
Yeah.
As opposed to what else?
I guess I don't
understand the question.
Yeah, what I mean is
that, for example,
take the propagating wave.
The propagating
wave is e to the i--
let's say forward--
kz minus omega t.
The standing wave is cosine
kz e to the minus i omega t.
I'll step ahead a little bit,
and write something awful.
This is actually a wave.
What we'll see is called
a diffraction integral.
And you can see it is nothing--
even though it looks
really complicated,
it is just a superposition.
Because the integral
is a summation.
And then what I have
here is a phasor,
and I put a lot of
these phasors together.
What they all share is this
term, e to the i minus I
omega t.
Actually, to be
strictly correct,
I should really carry this term.
I'm not really
allowed to drop it.
But because it is
the same always,
I might as well just
as well not write it.
So it basically
saves me writing.
And also confusion,
because as you know,
the more things you
write, the more likely
you are to make mistakes.
It is typical in
these derivations.
If you don't need
something, you drop it.
Because if you start carrying
it around, it involves mistakes.
So that's why I
would drop this term.
So I can just as well say that
if I have a propagating wave,
I can just write
it as e to the ikz.
That's a propagating wave.
I have a standing wave.
I can just as well
write it cosine kz.
OK, the e to the i minus i
omega t is implicit, right?
If I have this
diffraction integral,
I can just write it
without this term.
But again, the term is implicit.
If I have to figure out what
is the temporal variation
of the wave, I have
to put it back in.
And again, I cannot do it if
I have two waves of different
frequencies.
If I have e to the i omega.
Let me write another
superposition. e
to the i k1 z minus
omega one t, plus e
to the i k2 z minus omega 2t.
That's still a valid
superposition, right?
Provided that the ratios
of these, k1 over omega 1
equals c.
k2 over omega 2 equal c.
Still a valid superposition.
I'm not violating anything.
But I cannot do the
phasor trick anymore.
I have to keep the e
to the i omega times,
or I will make a mistake.
There's one more
case when if you
produce any kind
of nonlinearity,
where well we'll see later.
And again, we're going
a little bit ahead.
I'm in trouble.
These are from the quiz.
We'll a little bit later.
When we try to compute the
flux of electromagnetic energy,
there's something called
the pointing vector, which
is defined as the electric field
cross with the magnetic field.
If you tried to write the
expression for the pointing
vector, you cannot just multiply
the phasors of the electric
and the magnetic field,
because it's a product.
So you can use phasors only
when you have linear operations,
such as addition or integrals.
In this case, you can't.
We will see what
you do in this case.
You do a temporal average.
There's a few
cases where one has
to be careful with this phasor.